[Music]
have you heard your grandparents being
nostalgic about the past they say things
like earlier there used to be trees here
or we would wake up to the sound of
birds now can you tell me why this isn't
a reality anymore
for starters we could blame ourselves
for wanting huge buildings and wide
roads where has the natural cover of
forests disappeared in truth we have cut
down all those trees in the name of
development can you tell me what this
process is called where many trees and
plants are cut out yes we call it
deforestation clearing up forests for
human benefit is called deforestation
can you name a few reasons why man
clears up forest lands agriculture
that's right we can learn to bring more
land under cultivation what are the
reasons can you think of yes for
building factories houses and roads and
what about cutting trees for wooden fuel
isn't that another reason of course it
is man has cut trees over the years and
do you know this very action has caused
some serious reaction yes we call them
consequences we cannot get away by
reducing the green cover on a planet
trees and plants are a part of an
ecological chain and they maintain a
specific balance let us see how many
deforestation consequences you are able
to identify from the following pictures
you can now imagine the extent of
consequences deforestation has can't you
let us look at each of these in a little
more detail trees and plants give out
oxygen and use carbon dioxide during
photosynthesis with reduced plants and
trees the level of carbon dioxide on the
earth is increasing carbon dioxide
cannot escape into space and like many
other harmful gases it is creating a
blanket of heat around the earth this
increasing heat has led to a famous
phenomenon known as
woman this is the cause of the increase
in the temperature of the earth do you
know that according to studies the last
few decades of the 20th century have
been hottest in the last 400 years this
can create a chain of events
high temperatures affect the water cycle
glaciers melt at an alarming pace soil
cannot hold excess water during rainfall
or even rise in sea level both these
events can cause floods on the other
hand any change in the water cycle can
also lead to droughts haven't you
noticed the erratic climate changes in
your area these are all results of
deforestation let us see how the water
table is affected due to deforestation
trees and plants have roots which hold
the soil and allow water to percolate
into the soil with trees around what it
is not runoff carrying away with it the
topsoil this means that absence of trees
would cause increased soil erosion
removal of topsoil layer and reduced
underground water levels soil that is
devoid of its top layer is infertile and
gradually open lands become deserts this
process is called desertification land
that had once harbored rich trees and
wildlife now remains a desert devoid of
all life what about pollution as already
stated increased release of harmful
gases has caused global warming this
pollutes the air around us it is
therefore evident that all consequences
are interrelated rampant cutting down of
trees will only add to more problems
around us what can we do to prevent this
can be repair the damage done to know
more watch our next video
[Music]